hello
everybody if you like wild people you
are gonna love this episode
because we got eric andre and it's like
a big
boulder that just starts rolling and
rolling and going faster and faster by
the end of this episode it's like an
out of control wild ride oh my god
it gets crazy so strap on your seatbelts
and let's do it
ladies and gentlemen eric andre
yeah dude i want to
introduce you to my co-host scott
randall wow right off the bat look at
that first time you're doing scott
thank you how you doing eric good you
guys ever met
never met in person no what's up my man
that much
i like your shirts are those parrots
yeah that's some south florida boca
raton [ __ ] right there huh that's
what i'm talking about are you from boca
steve or your parents live there
or i'm not from anywhere man i grew up
all over the world
five different countries to be precise
but uh florida was home base
where did you go to high school i went
to high school in
england london england
where were you born i was actually born
in england as well
but uh spoke my first words in brazil in
portuguese
uh so i went to nursery school
in venezuela speaking spanish i went to
kindergarten in
darien connecticut first grade through
half a fourth in in miami then moved to
england when i was nine
canada when i was 12 and uh
back to england for all four years of
high school so why do people
tell me you're from boco mom divorced
dad
and moved to boca raton okay so you got
family involved right i live yeah i
should have just said that yeah i got
family there because
it's not about me dude it's not about me
but i mean it's worth asking you
probably get asked all the time
how does uh a 700 year old
jewish woman fall in love with a guy
from haiti
my parents met during a rent strike in
1970 my dad was escaping
a dictator in haiti in
1969 1970 this guy named duvalier
and moved to manhattan with his brother
and met my mom during a rent strike in
manhattan and then they
[ __ ] a rent strike huh they weren't
happy with what they were being
performed
or paid to perform in the musical rent
[Laughter]
no there was like the water was coming
out brown out of the tap i mean it was
the 70s in new york it was all chaotic
why couldn't i just said that that was
funny plainly
[ __ ] mumble it i like the stumble
like
you caught you caught him off guard like
an old jalopy right
yeah okay i thought that was hilarious
so did were you ever able to ride the
sibian on the howard stern show while
you ate viagra
i sure did i'm glad you asked um yes
i was and you know what the viagra
didn't really do it for me i never
i didn't get fully erect are you done by
aggressive steve
um have i done i've done cialis and it
didn't do that much for me
does that violate the terms of your
sobriety since it's not psychoactive
i i wouldn't consider that a sobriety
issue no
it's only psychoactive it's a dick issue
yeah it's not it's not uh
shoulders and up but you know the pill
that i would be after
if i was after a dick pill it would be
the one to make me not
come so fast oh you're a fast user
i mean historically yeah you know like
if uh
if i was dealing with strange then you
know what i'm
like what can we cut out she can't
[ __ ] listen to this one she didn't
like that don't they make those
premature wipes i've seen like uh
yeah premature wipes you ever thought
about trying those i don't have to worry
about it anymore because i'm in a
committed relationship you know and
and we do great but uh do you ever come
too quick in the relationship
no like we're in rhythm we're in a
rhythm are you in a relationship these
days
yes i am and i come very slow i'm like
you know when you're out of
like at the end of the jar of honey and
it just slowly oozes out
all right that's how i that's how slow
my ejaculator is released
okay okay now uh
there's of course the the netflix
special and that's uh
why i called your mother a 700 year old
jewish woman
you say that in the special pretty
aggressive
stuff in there i really like the the the
open
sorry you know the the whole intro
you got this uh on bourbon street you're
dressed up as a cop falling out of a cop
car with a bunch of beer bottles and
all drunk and pulling out drugs
everywhere it's a good time
and all the way through to the end
you've got uh you know people
simulating sex on stage is that
something that you would do like on the
whole tour or did you just do that
special for the
the taping well i didn't do a hidden
camera prank as a cop
understood i mean the stuff that was on
everything
the old white couple coming out yeah no
no that was just for the special so for
for the tour i just had like a throwaway
joke like
your parents are here right now come on
out and then towards the very end
my assistant like remind me he's like
where are you gonna get like
two elderly actors to come out and play
the like
fool the audience at the thinking of his
actual parents and i was like oh [ __ ] i
totally forgot about that so last minute
i called my producer and we're like
let's cast two
like boomers to like gratuitously french
kiss
so somebody in new orleans matched that
description and then we like found those
two people like very last minute that's
the kind of thing you gotta do
to rise above everybody else
yeah now is this the same tour where
you were on was it chris rock's private
jet
was that no that was his that was his
tour that's not
that ain't my tour it's like sprinter
vans and uh
you know [ __ ] george johnson and that
was when he was putting together the
the tambourine special yes yes it was a
little bit of a bigger budget
tour than my store i flattered wasn't it
uh
like chris rock and dave chappelle and
eric andre all on a private jet together
uh i i wasn't on the private jet with
dave
but uh i just opened um
a couple shows here and there for chris
and then dave would
pop in like random cities and stuff like
that but like
my last time opening for chris was our
fourth show in new orleans
and i bombed so hard
harder than i have in like years
just like in front of how many people
bugs splat against the window
uh probably 3500 people wow
more upsetting to have chris rock
witness that or 3 500 people from new
orleans
a little bit of both but he was so sweet
and supportive he like hugged me
afterwards he was like
yes that's awesome and he goes ask me
what happened when prince opened up for
the rolling stones for the first time
i go what what happened he goes everyone
booed prince they threw
bottles at him they were like dad i'm
off that [ __ ] stage
and he goes ask me what happened last
time i did i performed in london
i go what happened he goes i [ __ ]
bombed i [ __ ] ate a bag i think he
was like
so sweet about it and like him and his
tour manager were like don't worry about
it bombing's awesome
they were really really sweet and
supportive how much time and then he
asked
and then like a week later he asked me
to like open up for him in like
australia and i had to film something
and i couldn't
so he's um he's always been like really
now when you say i had to film something
are you talking about this movie bad
trip which you made with uh our jackass
director jeff tremaine
uh i can't remember maybe
probably it feels like that was around
the same time is it safe to say
that you are the
single most completely [ __ ] by a
coronavirus individual in the world
because you had this movie where the i'm
is it it was paramount did bad trip uh
uh no
mgm okay mgm and now
if if i'm correct knowing a little bit
about the movie business
uh there's the budget of the movie um
and then whatever the budget is for for
a given movie
the the the studio that makes it will
spend more on what's called pna
promotion and advertising getting all
the billboards out there all the
trailers the commercials
right and and and the movie studio in
your case for this
phenomenally incredible hidden camera
prank movie called bad trip
they went ahead and spent all that pna
money right you you had those
trailers everywhere did you get the
billboards up already too
no they didn't they didn't spend that
much money they didn't they definitely
didn't spend
as much or double the budget not more
than the budget
i wish they did but digital digital
billboards
i saw that [ __ ] trailer and it has to
be the most
genius [ __ ] dominating trailer
ever thanks man and and and and all this
promotions running and then all of a
sudden
coronavirus shuts everything down what
like one
week before your movie was one week
before south
by southwest i was the
most like biblical punishment
excruciating emotional pain i've ever
been through
but the saving grace is netflix
bought the movie and they're gonna and
they have 185
million subscriptions and uh
click of a bunk button act so people you
know all around the world will have
click of a button access to the movie
so i think that that is the silver
lining but
the beginning of my chord chain was um
unbelievably
emotionally painful when i think of
people who got [ __ ] over by the
coronavirus they think of motley crew
they had a sold out stadium tour
and i think of eric andre yeah okay
yeah i mean they're also people who are
dying
me and yeah they grew up people on
[ __ ] respirators people out there
that have it worse
touche i'll give you that that's uh i
like that
um okay and the movie's gonna be on
netflix and that place is just an
awesome
platform so i i think that and it takes
the pressure off the box office and all
that [ __ ] so yeah but does it take the
pressure off of you getting paid
yeah it takes the pressure off of me
actually making any income uh after
working on a movie for six and a half
seven years
right is that how long it took i mean
dude this was uh
quite quite a while i mean i don't know
about six or seven years but
but yeah we started we started the
humble beginnings of developing the idea
when we first started talking about it
and start
started meeting jeff was like beginning
in 2014. wow okay
well no ma'am and i mean dude and i
didn't get to see the movie
but uh just that trailer blew me away
dude with the blender
well well we we we're talking about
having a
drive-in movie theater premiere for it
so we would love to cordially invite you
cool
both of you as our as our guests
thank you the netflix business model is
to buy something out entirely
right like uh there's no back end
there's no
right you don't have any profit
participation yeah they just bought it
out and netflix owns it forever
you want me to share screen i'll pull up
the contract
let's get let's go let's have my lawyer
on the back and let's get the real nitty
gritty inside baseball
really get the audience's yeah that's an
unintended comedy i'm scoring
this is [ __ ] great good speaking of
uh a [ __ ] comedy dude like performing
in a comedy club with you has been one
of the
more memorable things like uh i remember
you doing a whole set
where it was just like kicking over
furniture
oh yeah that's right where was it with
you and bam yeah
and we were howling we were having the
best the hardest we ever laughed in a
comedy
club i forget if uh if if eric went like
through the audience kicking over
furniture
or if he was just uh no i was i was
dragging the empty chairs
onto the stage and just like drop like
acid dropping them like onto the shade
like clunk
and they had nothing to do with the
jokes they were just making the audience
completely uncomfortable
is that something you just did at the
laugh factory or is that what you do on
tour
i know i was just doing that in the
moment and the more bam and stevo were
laughing and the audience the rest of
the audience wasn't laughing
the more i was doing it i was just like
so appreciative
of these guys i grew up watching loving
it and the more i alienated the audience
the more they were
the louder they were laughing so it was
like they were like the two old guys
from the muppet show but they were like
positive energy rather than the negative
energy just like up in the balcony just
like you're howling with last night
after we were precisely up in the
balcony up to your left man i can't
believe you remember it that well how
long ago was that
that was uh it was a while eight years
ago maybe yeah
i saw you live when i was in high school
or maybe you know in college
with ryan dunn and
you guys played at this abandoned wind
dixie in boynton beach
that they turned into a club called
orbits and you were stapling underwear
to your
body and you were doing human tequila
shots and
dunn was throwing up on stage and it was
like the most lawless show
like like people were just jumping on
stage
everybody came backstage afterwards
there was like
complete lawlessness was so utter
it was so punk rock and exciting it was
one of the most memorable
show live shows i've ever seen it was so
space man um
experimental and and awesome and you
were so
i was at
that you could do that after that entire
tour decades
every uh radio interview every ad
whatever every promotion of that tour i
promised
that i would be drunk and on drugs
that's so good what was your
drug of choice it was nitrous right not
at that time at that time it was uh
cocaine ketamine wheat adderall
adderall wasn't really a thing yet at
that point you gotta understand my
friend
my friend calls adderall diet coke okay
nice i love that yeah dude um
when i think of you as well like i mean
i'll never forget that night at the lab
factory
but if there's one thing that that you
stand out in my mind it's that you
love birthdays more than like maybe even
more than my fiance
and she [ __ ] loves birthdays but you
make a big deal out of it every single
year
wow i guess i'm not i'm not religious so
i don't have any holidays except my own
uh birth which i guess is narcissistic
but
i just like going out for my birthday i
used to
have this little [ __ ] i used to live
in this little [ __ ] shoebox
apartment
in hollywood on santa monica
and wilcox like kind of by vine santa
monica and vine by the army and navy
store
and it was total rat's nest and um
i used to when i first first few years
of the eric andre show i was actually
making money and because i was like
scraping by for the first the many many
years when i lived here
but then i started making money but i
still lived in the [ __ ] shoebox
so i was saving up my money but my
birthday i would splurge and get a bunch
of camels and zebras and exotic animals
and cram them into the driveway of my
apartment building
and then we would get like illegal
fireworks and i would like
we would like huff ether those are the
best ones because
i was like cramming my apartment full of
people like a clown car
and doing all these exotic drugs and
partying with animals we had a stripper
that had a house arrest anklet
uh on one year those were like
that was the glory day of the party as
the party expanded it kind of just
became like a fun
regular party but there's nothing
regular about your birthday party every
year it's a different thing
every year in here it's a different
theme i still have in my closet one of
these wigs you have like
these these uh fancy wigs for everybody
from one of your birthday parties i went
to but you just said about getting
exotic animals
did people yell at you for having exotic
animals at your birthday party
no the the don't let my fiance hear that
she'll get very upset with you
the neighbors were so like
supportive the camel would walk around
like the zebra and you got to like hold
the
girls would love it because they got to
pet the baby goats and pet the little
bunnies and
like it was like a petting zoo you know
so i mean what's your budget
on on your birthday that's a great
question scott just asked and i have a
question for you
how good a sleep are you getting how
dope is your bed and pillow
setup because i'll tell you i'm a pillow
guy i got a closet full of pillows that
would blow your mind
and i am passionate about my bed
so glad i got my helix mattress because
ever since i did
my body feels better i'm more arrested
and this thing
is amazing because at helixsleep.com
they've got a two-minute quiz you plug
in your info and then they tell you
what's the best mattress for you
and by god they get it right because i
can't say enough good things about my
helix mattress
and if you go to helix sleep.com
stevo you get up to 200 off of any
mattress you want
and if you buy one they include two
free pillows i told you i'm a pillow guy
and i'm telling you
that helix pillows are the greatest
pillows i've
ever slept with so do yourself a favor
go to helix sleep.com
stevo take that two minute quiz and get
yourself
the best mattress in the world because
you're gonna thank me for it
now let's talk birthdays when i was
doing those they were probably
like i was probably dropping like
five grand on like animals and
and i would get like clowns and stilt
walkers and jugglers and
fire breathers and we had and he lived
in a small apartment
very small apartment that was like the
comedy of it like how much [ __ ] and
chaos can we cram in
i had a dj set up on top of my stove and
he accidentally turned the stove on and
his equipment caught on fire
and then my my neighbor next door
started was pissed and started throwing
glass bottles at people at the party
um my second a.d came in and ate like an
entire plate of weed brownies thinking
they were regular brownies and
i had like a really bad time but also
the gate broke open and just like
drifters from the neighborhood started
coming into my house those are
those are the days i miss those days
yeah dude i got a question for you steve
at what point in your life at what age
did you stop
to start hating birthdays like because
at 23 24 it's a party
and then 25 26 like i
i can tell you exactly when okay my 26th
birthday
i was working in the circus as a circus
clown i
showed up that day i did not tell a
single [ __ ] person
in the circus that it was my birthday i
uh
i i was i was uh i just felt like it's
not cool anymore man
not enough 26 too old but what'd you do
for your 25th birthday too old to be
psyched
uh my 25th birthday i was at the time of
your life
i was performing in a in a nightclub
like getting drunk and breathing fire
and clown makeup and uh i blacked out
and
blacked out completely uh but yeah i
just think birthdays make me older and
and got it you look for the amount of
drugs and booze and toxins you put in
your body you look incredibly
handsome and you are aging gracefully i
mean you don't look you look exactly
like you have for the past 20 years i
don't i do not get it i have like
three cocktails and i just age
like eric stoltz in that movie mask
was that rocky dennis yeah rocky dennis
i'm like
dennis you you look you look
you look gorgeous nitrous has
preservatives in it
you know i i i think that that's very
kind and wonderful i think you're uh
you're
agent gracefully you're a silver fox you
don't have silver hair but
i do you only gonna look more handsome
with time
well thanks man speaking he just
mentioned nitrous
and i remember was it for your birthday
one year you were like hey steve oh man
like how do i get a nitrous tank and
then i think you called back and you
were like hey was that like
insensitive of me to ask yeah yeah and i
was like that was shitty were you sober
i was i was like if anybody knows where
to get the dentist tank because i love
that dentist grade nitrous
not the little whippets when you get
that [ __ ] medical nitrous that that
is like the champagne of beers oh what
there's different types of nitrous yeah
there's there's the kind that you make
actual whipped cream with you get the
little cartridges and it's like pretty
uh
it's not clean it's it's uh pretty
shitty i think uh it
it it's arguably got a lot to do with my
why my voice is such a piece of [ __ ]
cause i did so much of that
[ __ ] unclean shitty whippet nitrous
then there's
auto grade nitrous which is even worse
and this is like the [ __ ] tanks that
they use to make the cars go super fast
and people will actually huff that but
that's the worst [ __ ] thing in the
world
and then there's what the dentist gives
you now the dentist when they give it to
you
they'll mix it with oxygen so you're
getting a real like kind of a mellow
version you're never going to pass out
but what he's talking about doing is is
just taking that
dentist and just doing 100 nitrous just
straight to the dome
you're like a nitrous someone yes and
right after i asked i felt so guilty
i didn't care one bit i thought it was
hilarious and and to this day
uh particularly with this new comedy
special we should tell everybody
so it's called legalize everything and
the [ __ ] eric andre is out of his
goddamn mind it's insane
it's fantastic and hilarious um
but largely your your new netflix
special
is about your drug experiences i mean
you're just just
coming in hot tired you're like running
through uh with the cocaine you know the
helmet the
with the cocaine straws and yeah i got
me starting to hotmail with the ref
or something yeah yeah i love the joke
about i got my [ __ ] crystal meth card
my medicinal crystal bath card [ __ ]
genius
and you're talking about all that the
acid is your favorite drug and
you know i'm getting stoned with my mom
and at a certain point i gotta wonder
a how much of that is true like you know
this enthusiasm for drugs
and uh and b do you ever get concerned
that being so
pro-drug and pro-taking drugs
uh if that's gonna have any kind of uh
like you know a detrimental effect you
know
i think there's a difference between
drug use and drug abuse
and i think that if you take crystal
meth medicinally
yes exactly it made me think about like
cleaning from the doctors i want to get
i want to get a service rattlesnake
yeah no i think well i 100 smoked pot
with my mom
um it used to be my favorite jerk but i
actually think honestly
coffee is my favorite drug yeah i
pounded every show
man i drank that drink out of this
[ __ ]
i drink it every day it's always good to
me
i don't crash i it just makes me
happy it makes me creative coffee out of
all the drugs i've done
is by far the best one it's like just
most consistent
never lets you down coffee is the number
one imported exported drug in the world
do you have a cut off point like is
there a time of day that you won't drink
coffee after
i i only do a cup or two in the morning
because um if i do it after lunch or if
i do a lot of espresso
i can't sleep i have too much on my mind
i'm too anxious what time do you say
crystal meth the math method's around
like four or four
is it true that uh is it true that you
bought an eight ball of cocaine in new
orleans one time
i think i changed that town to town that
that eight ball story where i go
i ripped it and i was like i think i
just knew the drywall
is actually from when i bought it off
the streets in costa rica
in this like touristy beach town from a
shade ball dude
and i was with my ding dong friends and
they were like let's
let's buy coke off a shady shady magoo
and i was like yeah of course that's a
great
idea and i [ __ ] ripped the line and i
was like
that was ninety percent drywall 10 baby
laxative
at all yeah i would expect that you
would get good cocaine in costa rica see
like for example best coke i ever had
was in in brazil
brazil okay that was that was that was
real i heard the really really good coke
is like blue
or it's like a different different color
it's like off-white
off-white like a little yellow and yeah
i never saw
that in my uh you know cocaine cowboys
documentary you ever did coke in south
america
dude like mike's this is gonna people
will call me a bad person for sharing
this but anybody who's going to mexico
as a tourist just a little piece of
information for you
every single [ __ ] taxi driver
in uh and say cancun or or acropolis you
say
hey man i want cocaine they'll either
have it under their seat
in the taxi cab or they'll go to the
taxicab stand and just get it from the
the guy right there but you every single
maybe in all of mexico but definitely
cancun
every single taxi driver is also a
cocaine dealer
you're more used to mexico and for that
matter the cocaine is like really pretty
[ __ ]
good man it's like powerful cocaine
coming from these taxi
guys the prices are all over the place
but then
like watch out when you're in the
bathroom because the bathroom attendant
guy
if he hears you snorting in the bathroom
these little [ __ ] [ __ ] will
like climb over or under [ __ ] they'll
grab you and then you got to bribe them
to get out of it
ooh that sucks yeah that happened
i think we might have even been in costa
rica
we had that same thing happened to us
but
what do i want to come over i can't
remember how old were you when you first
got high steve
were you doing drugs since you were like
12. um no
first time smoking pot 16.
drunk first time drunk uh i mean
i've been like on my own initiative i
was 12.
what about you eric first time doing
acid
acid not till i was like 21 but uh
drunk we would we would we would
get not 40 ounces because they were any
where they were illegal in
in florida we would get quarts of old
english for say night special brew
we would listen i had a mix tape with
all these different easy
e songs on it and we were listening to
easy e on our walkman
or cd discman and skateboard poorly
and drink quarts of old english until we
threw up
that was like in like in like plantation
in fort lauderdale and hollywood and
like i had like my alien workshop
skateboard i couldn't even ollie and i
would just like
drink and listen to easy dozen to like
[ __ ] puke
like a rainbow-colored saint-eyed
special bro drink like mad dog 2020
wine coolers now the ice that's so gross
growing up in boca raton were you like
uh
were your parents well off like you
think of boca raton is like a wealthy
community
yeah my parents are i mean my dad's a
psychiatrist
um my mom like did um
she like tutored old people computers my
dad would have been better off my dad's
like
not great with money he's like
very caribbean like he gambles and he
like
plays like lottery and like he just like
always squandered his dough so we were i
was
never starving but um
uh i wish that he handled his
his finances are your parents still
together
no they got divorced when i was like 12
13 but they're still friends
they still live up the street from each
other and
um they
they like get along better now than when
they were married i feel like you know
what i mean they still like my mom goes
over my dad's house all the time they're
like pals
you mentioned fort lauderdale did you
ever go to the fort lauderdale swap shop
i never did the swap shop i never did
the swap shop i think i was too young i
didn't have
access to the swap shop it's the world's
largest flea market
slash amusement park slash circus
said that's where i was a clown yeah
what year what years were you a clown
there
96 97 year 2000 about 2 000
yeah um okay so let's talk
like you know jackass and [ __ ] you know
when i say talk jackass i mean working
with the jackass director
jeff tremaine you developed that whole
bad trip movie
right where like uh what's your uh what
what's your take on working with jeff
germain i mean
for us you know making jackass movies i
think
we would all agree that he's a bad
person you know putting us in harm's way
you know putting us in harm's way he's
kind of an evil
sort of a dude you know he's like always
like
just looking for terrible things to
happen to us but but your experience is
probably a little bit different like
what's your take on the guy
yeah he is uh jeff is the
prank master he kind of knows exactly
like what will yield the highest results
and he kind of had to steer me in the
direction of
of um the marks are the stars
he's like you're you think you think i'm
a comedian i'm going to get the laugh in
the scene but like
you're really engineering these pranks
to get the
the marks will have like the biggest
laughs in the screenings
and when we did those first couple test
screenings i was like
holy [ __ ] you're right we went into the
reshoots
engineering the uh
we're like fine tuning the pranks to get
the marks
really riled up and invested in the
situation so he was really like
a mentor father figure to me throughout
the whole process because i was coming
just in from eric andre show where we we
don't have to worry about story
none of the pranks make any [ __ ]
sense it's just like a nonsense
punk rock bang bang bang quarter hour
absurdist adult swim show but he was
very much
like the story has to be grounded and
the character has to be
likable and relatable and
like the pranks have to function like
scenes so he he was really like my
obi-wan kenobi all through the process
he is a [ __ ]
nice man i appreciate i appreciate jeff
he is he i mean dude there's a reason
why he's so
damn successful is because he's really
that talented
ah i hate to say it but he's back
but he said he told me that he gives it
to you guys way worse he's like
because he the more you guys are
tortured and punished the better the
editors
it wasn't it wasn't quite the same thing
for our movie like jackass where
we're getting attacked by pythons and
bulls and right
um getting take getting tasered and [ __ ]
like that you know what i mean you do
you do pranks and stunts whereas we were
just doing pranks
he you said something interesting we
said when we went into reshoots
does that change the direction of the
story
you know like because the story is based
on how the pranks go
so you sort of the reshoots gelled all
the story
together it was like all the gaps and
the holes
got filled up um by the material we
got in the reshoots when did tiffany
haddish come into it
pretty much from the beginning of
production so the first day we shot
rel and i got a knife pulled out on us
we went into this barber shop in the
hood
with our dicks stuck in a chinese finger
trap and we went into the barber shop
and we were like hey man you got any
scissors get us out of this chinese
finger trap
and this barber dude was like oh hell no
and he started looking for his gun
couldn't find his gun grabbed his knife
we ran out me and rel are like joint
conjoined at the dick so he can barely
run
guys like [ __ ] chasing things with a
knife
i forget my safe word my safe words
popcorn so i'm looking at jeff and the
first ad and all that my director i'm
like
goosebumps goosebumps goosebumps my
adrenaline's so high i forget my own
safe word which is popcorn i start
shouting goosebumps then i'm like i look
at this
our security guard i go i'm sorry
popcorn he jumps out grabs a guy with a
knife
hey man sorry you're on a hidden camera
show and the guy was with the knife was
like
oh man y'all are hilarious dude where's
this [ __ ] come out
and he's like you shouldn't be doing
these pranks in this neighborhood
he's like you're lucky i didn't bring my
gun to work damn so
because of that so to answer your
question because of that rel almost quit
he never did hang camera pranks before
he goes you guys are gonna get me
[ __ ] killed
i'm [ __ ] over this [ __ ] i got kids i
cannot be murdered
um i'm done he went home we thought we
lost rel he called tiffany haddish
because they're good friends he's like
i'm doing this [ __ ] eric andre movie
we had a knife pulled out on me this
guy's gonna get me killed tiffany starts
like dying laughing
five minutes later she calls me and she
goes yo you almost got real killed at
work today i go
yeah and then she goes yo i want to be
in your movie
all right and the girl that
the woman the woman that played her
um real sister in the movie just dropped
out so i was like tiffany we actually
have an available
there's only four cast members and one
just dropped out so like
it was just the universe providing us
with that
is one of the most talented comedians in
the world dude i've done comedy with
tiffany haddish i got footage of her
bringing me up on stage at the laugh
factory from 2006.
like i mean dude it was like your first
time on stage or second time or
something right right
it was uh i mean this is like way back
in the day and she's just always been so
supportive of me doing my stand-up and
giving me tags and and jokes i remember
i had this joke about
how uh i jack off so much that my dick
is like off to an angle because i've
been pushing it that way because i'm
right-handed my dick goes that way
and i remember tiffany says uh she goes
oh when you do they say my dick's like a
beyonce
song to the left to the left
steve when you guys were filming did you
ever have safe words or things like that
yeah there's like oklahoma i forget when
um
when uh we electrocuted my balls what
the safe board was
i don't think it serves me to have a
safe word like uh
you ever used a safe word yeah when i
was when they were executing my balls
you actually said i said it too quick i
shouldn't have [ __ ] had a safe word
oh
that's the problem with safe words they
ruined the bit
yeah i went back and watched a bunch of
old wild boys and i think that's [ __ ]
scarier than anything almost in jacka i
was like you're [ __ ] with
great white sharks yeah and gorillas and
silverback gorillas and gators you're
[ __ ] out of your
mind and bears how did you not get
[ __ ]
killed how did you not get injured by
those [ __ ] predators
there's a youtube video that uh we're
getting ready to put together
called times i could have died and
there's nothing
there's like not one jackass seen in it
it's
all wild yeah [ __ ]
what animal are you scared of the most
is there anyone in particular
i already could catch enough heat for
talking about myself though a podcast
just to stop it
no no i want to know because jeff told
me
what he thinks is the scariest animal he
said there's only one animal he'll never
work with again or something like that
oh it's like a scarce one i want to see
if it's the same one
he's probably going to say the wombat
right
no he said the wombat was gnarly but he
said chimpanzees
wow he's like he's like don't want to
[ __ ] with them
what they rip they rip off your genitals
they rip out your eyes they chew off
your fingers and then they continue to
attack you oh the chimpanzees
but he's not saying that based on any
experiences that we
had ourselves he's he's basing that on
like [ __ ] you read in the news
where they totally rip off your face and
your dick and eat it
and not necessarily like that old guy
brought brought a cake into the zoo
and the other the other chimps got
jealous and ripped off his dick and
[ __ ] tore his arms off yeah
yeah i think that's what he was talking
about i don't remember us having an
experience with chimpanzees
what's with the wombat it was just the
angriest
one you know it's it was to marsupial
the wombat it was in uh
uh i feel like we were in tasmania and
it was just the [ __ ] angriest most
aggressive
just [ __ ] pissed off creature that we
ever encountered
isn't it didn't you burn an entire
village in south africa down the first
day of shooting and then
pontius like jumped in a hut and saved
two
german journalists or something and
absolutely insane
i do remember oh i remember
i was confusing the stories but yeah it
was british journalists
we were in south africa we burned down
three cabins
and uh once we realized we couldn't put
it out we're breaking all these windows
and everything
screaming everybody get out we're all
like bloodied from smashing
windows and we did save the the lives of
the two
journalists and they did write an
article about us being heroes who saved
their lives but you caused the fire
that that just reminded me of when we
were at tony hawk's
50th birthday party and you came over
and you were like dude
tell me the story about the wu-tang clan
brought up that story when he
interviewed me the other day amazing
that story just
goes around it just like makes world
tours over and over i know
dude and i'm never i i'm never looked
good in that story
dude what's the story it was okay
maybe it was 2006 the rock the bells
festival which is like a big rap
festival
headlined by the wu-tang clan i show up
i'm just drinking all day i'm out of my
mind
and i've just recently dialed in
you know i do this the the the double
back where i'm gonna flip back and forth
and it's a mangina
but i just i just got dialed in the
double back back flip so i'll flip my
balls into a mangina and then do a
standing back flip yeah
and like so they're gonna have
they're gonna have a um an odb
tribute that's two years three years
after odb died
two years and um i go up to memphis man
i'm like dude i got it
during the odb tribute i'm gonna get
butt
naked i'm gonna flip my balls back i'm
gonna do a standing back flip
and he's like laughing he's like you
know and uh and then a little while
later he comes up because dude you can't
do it man they're gonna
[ __ ] you up and i go ah cool man that's
what otb would want dude he'd love that
yeah
[ __ ] rad so like during the odb
tribute like i remember method me i
wasn't too sure but then [ __ ] but then
he just hands me the mic so i'm like hey
so i addressed this crowd of like this
is a huge outdoor
festival there's so many people and i
address this crowd i'm like
i'm i'm like i was in uh
you know protective custody in la county
jail
facing eight years in prison and they
told me that i was in
odb cell because he was in there so much
of the time
so i feel his connection to odb and in
his honor right now
i just get butt naked i do my trick i
hug
odps mom right like after doing it
they start playing uh brooklyn zoo you
know like a couple of big odb
hits and like a couple tunes after the
fact all of a sudden
rayquan just just he's had enough
he comes over and he grabs he stops
everything grabs me up by my neck
because she says
you're gonna apologize or i'm gonna [ __ ]
you up in front of all these people and
i don't care if i'm going to jail
like like our brother wasn't here to
defend himself from that
and i'm like and he's got me by the neck
and i'm like i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm tired
i'm so sorry sorry you know and uh
and like and then i apologize and he let
me go and and uh
the concert resumed and and someone came
up to us said hey it's not safe for you
to be here you know you guys so they had
like
they escorted us he did that in front of
everybody
oh on stage in front of everybody and i
have the footage
yeah i've seen the footage i've been
dying to make this video
is get someone from like getting
you know maybe rayquan i don't know have
you talked to him since
i saw rizza at something and i i just
went up to him and i said hey where's it
like
oh you know i want to acknowledge that
you know that like to the extent that
that was disrespectful man like
i uh just you know i want to acknowledge
that that was wrong
and uh [ __ ] that you should have doubled
down and did it again
no stop so i'm so sick of public
apologies just be like
hey i was drunk i was having a good time
odb had a sense of humor sorry
i mean to be fair there was one time i
did a show with odb before he died
and uh it was at this like hammerstein
ballroom in new york city and like um
before like uh there's all these
different rooms with shows going on i go
into odb
odb was on stage smoking a big
blunt of pure pcp and i know it was pure
pcp because he said so and he was
sharing it with audience members
i pulled out my little camera and i have
this footage too to this day
i have this footage of him and like he's
rapping like there's all these different
little clips that i shot on this thing
right he's just smoking this
piece then next thing you know oh and by
the way he's rapping with his [ __ ]
pants down around his ankles his
his cocking balls completely out totally
out
and uh and and i mean like so like
he was uncircumcised i could tell you
that because i saw
you know you know that an anteater yeah
and he's smoking this pcb ends up like
uh
he ends up sitting on the uh the drum
riser he's not even rapping anymore and
then like he just slumps over and passes
out
and i got footage of him like that yeah
yeah still holding the
hole
it's like uh almost like time lapse if
i'm just like
where where was this in new york new
york in new york in uh
2003. and was was he on stage by himself
he was uh i mean he had a bunch of like
his crew on stage okay yeah do you have
any wu-tang stories eric
like that nothing as
close to the power of those you got any
pcp stories yeah you ever do pcp
i smoked pcp when i was 13 i think by
accident like i had like a
uh they called it cloud9 like a joint
dipped in embalming fluid
and it was one of the first times i ever
smoked pot and i was like man
weed is crazy
and everything was like 8-bit and then
like years of smoking weed
after through high school i was like oh
that wasn't weed at all but it was like
my second or third time smoking weed so
um i went up to the rizza at a party one
time
and i was all drunk and embarrassed
myself and wrapped like six bobby
digital songs like in his face and i was
like
i'm such a fan and he's like oh okay
that's enough but like that story pales
in comparison to the power of both
stevo's
odb stories that one while he's alive
the one after he's alive i don't think
that was that disrespectful i think
those
guys are just old school you you meant
you you
your intentions were good and you were
coming i think that that's what
said it's not to worry about it he he
had never taken it personally he wasn't
offended also
also rae kwan was supposedly the grouch
of the group and rayquan almost left
wu-tang and rayquan and rizzo beefed for
a long time
so he's kind of like the controversial
member of the group
i don't think the other guys would have
done that to you what was disrespectful
about it that you were naked
hugging his mom i think i put my clothes
back on before i hugged his mom okay
i don't think i was that bad i think he
wanted like a sincere earnest moment
and he's from like the projects of
staten island that he just sees a naked
drug stevo flipping around and he's like
what the [ __ ] is going on right now
he's just like no he wanted to have like
a sincere like a
hum sober humble moment and in mind
his emotions are valid too but right if
i saw that if i was dead
and somebody was flipping around naked
in my honor i would be flattered
all right in my defense i [ __ ] nailed
that [ __ ] dude how clean was he landing
on that flip paul
the landing is it's good it's clean yeah
can you can you post that video why
don't you post it i could i just like
i'm sensitive to the the fact
of it being um you know like
i would want the blessing of uh of the
wu tang
you know i would i would no you got to
put it out okay
i kind of want that i kind of think also
with my producer hat on that
the story is kind of better without just
me telling it but like to get
like maybe raequan you know his version
of it you know so
like it would be really pretty
compelling if it was uh it's a little
bit of a group effort yeah we got to do
it justice
it's an intense story it's been on my
whiteboard for a long
i'll give you my answer
oh he wants to talk to me about that
like i mean it would be it would be
obvious and and
i've seen interviews where rayquan was
talking about it and like he
you know carries a grudge about it you
know like
he's not [ __ ] stoked and and you know
like i would love it
if uh there was a way to tell the story
i mean i don't need to look good in it i
don't like
could care you know like i was uh
completely you know he can be humiliated
and
and i'm okay with that but i would love
it if we could bury the hatchet
i think fan fan the flames of hatred
yeah yeah reach out to him have him like
calm down
let's prank him q a to camera and then
yeah prank him come out behind him with
your balls
like right behind his head
[Laughter]
speaking of which meditation dude i'm on
this crazy run of like
over a hundred and eighty straight days
averaging over 40 minutes of meditation
every day
i love that guy you're still how do you
feel i mean yeah
i think that uh it benefits me immensely
too
twice a day twice a day every day yeah
for how long have you done that for
since 2000 since eric andre show started
since 2012.
jesus there's something very very
uh correlated right there's some there's
between people who begin meditating and
then
all of a sudden are wildly successful
like eric andre here
like it's right when you started
meditating
the next day right
that's when i got into the illuminati
i just like calmed i i chilled the [ __ ]
out a little bit i was very very
that's hilarious i have a lot of
anxieties this is eric andre
chilled out yeah i mean not to say you
cocky time
[Laughter]
he chills out and watches the [ __ ] oh
dude and uh
but uh it's not chill on instagram dude
i remember have i not sent you texts
before where i'm like yo
dude you can't shoot your dick on
instagram dude like delete that [ __ ]
before they [ __ ] take your account
down
no you never you never you you've always
been supportive of my dick on it
on instagram dude i feel like i remember
thinking like dude you can't do that
eric you know like you're going to lose
oh never you've never sounded like a
real rayquam right now
i bet if i did if i didn't actually send
it to you right then i
have you ever gotten in trouble you've
got to have had dick pics taken down
off instagram yeah they they they always
take them down you know but i always put
them up i just picked him back
up yeah dude he's meditating it's all
good
right and and uh so i mean this is
everybody's chance to
to get your next dick pic by following
eric
[ __ ] andre yeah on instagram
yeah yeah is there a release on linkedin
is there a release date for the netflix
for the tv uh for the movie bad trip uh
no
we don't have a date yet pressure
netflix to give us a date we keep asking
them
but um i think i think i obviously think
they're like watching
if my special does well or not before
they give us a date
but uh that could be me being paranoid
but i think that these are different
patches of netflix yeah there's i'd say
netflix is like a big octopus and uh
i don't even think that the i think it's
apples and oranges
i mean your netflix special is fantastic
and everybody should watch it right now
if they haven't already
but thank you i think that's a different
deal
wasn't there a thing on wild boys where
you got your dick sucked by an octopus
and
s p want to let you show it
they have a little beak the octopus
right
we didn't get our dick sucked but there
was not there was definitely octopuses
with the beak
and and uh but we didn't get our dicks
well we got our
dicks why am i telling this
sucked by an animal no by a russian
prostitute
they called her the octopus
she had a beak i'm telling i'm not just
gonna tell luck she can't listen to this
episode she doesn't like to hear these
stories
just say eric was talking about animals
at his house and i don't want you to
hear it
yeah right but uh the thing with with uh
with wild boys
was that uh you know it was a constant
battle with the sensors it's called
standards and practices
you know like that we would submit the
episode and then the
the sensor board would would watch it
and they would say oh you got to take
this out you're going to take that out
so what we would do is we would
deliberately film
extra [ __ ] up [ __ ] to to include in
the cut
red herring exactly so that when the the
sensor said oh you know take this knife
oh well we gave you that so in our last
trip ever we uh
actually hired a couple russian
prostitutes to to
include in this polar bear skit where
you know like we did with the pandas we
would do these different like montages
and animal suits
and in what we submitted to standards
and practices
was a montage of polar bear activity and
in the montage was like the a circle
cut out for the for the dick dick coming
out and the pandas
the polar bear's getting his dick sucked
by russian prostitute and sure enough we
got the notes back
please cut out the the [ __ ] and then
oh my god yeah please
please air that next to the rayquan
footage
[ __ ] dude oh my god damn dude could you
imagine if you pranked raequan
after all that like you reached out to
him like the serious call
extend the olive branch it's
crazy because the wooten clan has just
had like such
a rebirth you know like they had their
their documentary
[ __ ] documentary and then they had a
whole scripted series
like the wu tang is arguably bigger than
they've ever been before so
i wonder uh didn't they have that they
had that album come out and that martin
shkreli bought it for like a million
dollars or something like that
do you remember that is that kid still
in jail one cd
pharmaceutical guy yeah he's still in
jail and he and he owns the [ __ ]
latest wu-tang album and nobody's heard
it
something like that jesus all right so
everybody's gonna fall out it's
eric [ __ ] andre on instagram
is there anything do you do any youtube
activity or anything
no youtube i have twitter and instagram
is insta is twitter
also eric [ __ ] andre twitter's just
eric andre
ah man which came out first eric andre
eric [ __ ] andre
twitter or instagram twitter twitter i
had first and then instagram
later then he started meditating
he fell in a better place and uh waste
no time in watching your special
it's called legalize everything on
netflix right now
and stay tuned for bad trip coming out
yes sir all right thank you guys yeah i
love you i appreciate you
hit me up man i'm coming over to watch
that rayquaza footage i'm not joking
whether you like it or not this is a
real loosey-goosey woman yeah
you were hilarious if you don't if you
don't let me watch that footage i'm
telling your wife
to listen to this episode sure all right
we'll see you soon hold in your house
all right see you guys later dog later
later guys bye-bye
i told you that [ __ ] was nuts man i was
even nervous about putting it out
unedited
i said [ __ ] it and uh
you know now that we're at the end of
the episode let me thank you for
sticking around this long and let me
remind you
that the helix mattresses really are
dope so give it a shot
helix sleep.com stevo
and all that stuff totally worth it uh
please let
eric andre know that you enjoyed the
episode and uh
i'm telling you some exciting things
coming up i'm really
really stoked so thank you for being
like
on this wild ride with me [ __ ] yeah
let's go wendy come on come on